let's look at this rocket sled here it's
going on in the snow but it wants to
stop there are two little devices
mounted on the sled and they can eject
gas and so the forward one is used to
eject gas to make the sled stop we want
to derive a different relation for the
differential between the speed of the
sled and the the differential of the
mass of the the rocket sled but before
we do that with a rocket equation we
need to actually consider what else we
know about this system well we know what
that the dry mass has a mass of M naught
the fuel mass is given also as M naught
and we know that at time of T equals
zero the speed of the sled is V naught
we also know that at a later time T plus
delta T we have the sled here whose mass
is now M of T plus delta T and we have
this little mass parcel that has been
ejected so the gas and that has the mass
of Delta M F so the mass of the fuel we
furthermore know that relative to the
sled this little gas parcel is moving
with a speed U the rocket equation says
that my force external force has two
terms we have the mass of the rocket
times the acceleration of the sled - the
differential here of the mass times the
speed U and these are actually all
vectors and so this describes this
little gas parcel here and this one
describes the rocket and we know that V
equals V I hat that's going in the right
in the direction of motion and u equals
u I had we also know
there are no external forces applied to
the sled so that's actually zero we can
then turn this equation we can apply all
of this we have we will get zero equals
M R DV DT minus DM R DT we can bring
this one on the other side and we end up
with the relationship that we wanted to
obtain namely the an equation that
contains the differentials of the speed
of the rocket the that sled and the
differential of the mass